NOW, THE KEY PEOPLE INVOLVED
NEED TO EXPLAIN THEMSELVES.
HERE WITH REACTION TONIGHT
WE WELCOME BACK TO THE
PROGRAM FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY
FOR THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
JOE DEGENERAL HAVE A
JUDICIAL WATCH PRESIDENT TOM
FITTON, FOX NEWS LEGAL
ANALYST GREGG JARRETT.
ALL RIGHT, JOE, IT'S A LOT
TO ABSORB.
A LOT OF INFORMATION.
BUT, IT'S SO TELLING AND SAD
AMERICA.
GIVE US YOUR GENERAL TAKE
AWAYS FROM THE NEW
INFORMATION TODAY THIS
INFORMATION TODAY.THIS
>> THIS IS PILING ON IN A
VERY BIG WAY.
VERY SAD ENDING FOR THE DOJ
AND FBI OFFICIALS.
WRAY IS GONE BECAUSE
McAY IS GONE BECAUSE
McCA IS GONE BECAUSE
McCAKES GONE BECAUSE
McCAKE WGONE BECAUSE
McCAKE WASNE BECAUSE
McCAKE WAS S BECAUSE
McCAKE WAS SENECAUSE
McCAKE WAS SENT PACKS AS A
RESULT OF CHRISTOPHER WRAY
BEING BRIEFED BY A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INVESTIGATION THAT'S
UNDERWAY, WHICH IS GOING TO
LEAD TO CRIMINAL CHARGES
AGAINST A NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING COMING
OUT NOW IN THE TEXT MESSAGES
IS JUST THE MINIMUM OF WHAT
IS AVAILABLE NOW TO DOJ
OFFICIALS AS THEY WATCH
SADLY.
>> Sean: WHO DO YOU THINK IS
GOING TO GET CHARGED, JOE?
I DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT.
>> I BELIEVE THAT SEVERAL,
SEVERAL HIGH FBI OFFICIALS
WILL BE CHARGED CRIMINALLY.
AND IT IS CONCEIVABLE THAT
SOME DOJ PEOPLE WILL ALSO BE
CHARGED CRIMINALLY.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT JAMES
COMEY?
THE INFORMATION ABOUT COMEY
IS FILTERED THROUGH OTHER
PEOPLE.
IT IS CLEAR THOUGH THAT AT
THE TIME PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION AND SUBSEQUENT TO
THE ELECTION, THERE WERE A
GROUP OF PEOPLE INSIDE THE
FBI AT THE SENIOR LEVELS ON
THE SEVENTH FLOOR WHO
DECIDED THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO PROTECT HILLARY CLINTON,
THEY WERE GOING TO CHANGE
302S AND THEY WERE GOING TO
MAKE.
>> Sean: 302S ARE WITNESS
TESTIMONIES.
>> THEY WERE GOING TO CHANGE
302 INTERVIEW NOTES.
THEY WERE GOING TO EXONERATE
SAYING.
AT THE "NEW YORK TIMES" AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WITH
GREAT CORRUPTION STORIES OF
AMERICAN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
BIGGEST?
>> I WOULD CONSIDER THIS THE
LARGEST LAW ENFORCEMENT
SCANDAL IN HISTORY FOR THIS
REASON.
THE ACTIVITIES OF MCCABE AND
OTHERS AND BRUCE OHR AND
OTHERS WERE DESIGNED TO
SUBVERT THE CONSTITUTION AND
A NATIONAL ELECTION.
THE MOST SERIOUS OFFENSE
UNDER OUR CONSTITUTION.
>> Sean: GREGG JARRETT,
LET'S START WITH THE NEW
STRZOK PAGE TEXT WE HAVE OUT
TODAY.
WE'RE STILL MISSING THE FIVE
CRUCIAL MONTHS ALTHOUGH THEY
HAVE BEEN RECOVERED.
WE HAVE A LOT MORE COMING.
THERE IS 50,000 IN TOTAL.
SO WITH EACH NEW REVELATION
IT GETS WORSE AND WORSE FOR
THEM.
MEANING OF SOME OF THE
VAGUENESS IN THESE TEXT
MESSAGES BUT IT'S ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR IN TODAY'S MESSAGES
JUST REINFORCED IT THAT
THERE WAS SUCH EXTREME
POLITICAL BIAS ON THE PART
OF STRZOK AND PAGE.
AND THEN THE PRESIDENT THAT
THESE TWO PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN NOWHERE NEAR THE
INVESTIGATION AND, YOU KNOW,
SOME PEOPLE HAVE SAID AND I
HAVE WATCHED THEM ON OTHER
PROGRAMS AND SAID WELL, WHEN
MUELLER FOUND OUT HE FIRED
STRZOK.
WELL, HE WAS ON THE HILLARY
CLINTON CASE, THE LEADER
INVESTIGATOR, THEN HE JUMPED
TO THE TRUMP-RUSSIA CASE.
THEN HE JUMPED TO THE
MUELLER CASE, SO FOR TWO
YEARS HOW MUCH DAMAGE DID HE
PROVIDE THE FISA TRANSCRIPT
HEARINGS, GREGG.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND SENATOR
GRASSLEY, THEY GOT A CHANCE
TO LOOK AT ALL FOUR FISA
APPLICATIONS.
THAT WAS SORT OF LIKE A
LAST NIGHT WITH THE
UNREDACTED MEMO THAT THEY
HAD.
AS IT RELATES TO THE INTEL,
I WOULD THINK THAT WE, IF WE
EVER GOT AHOLD OF THE FISA
COURT, CONSIDERING THEY ARE
SAYING THE BULK OF
INFORMATION TO ALLOW THIS TO
GO FORWARD WAS BASED ON THIS
PHONY HILLARY CLINTON PAID
FOR RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
DOSSIER, I CAN ONLY -- AND
THEY WITHHELD ALL THIS
INFORMATION FROM THE COURT,
CAN I GOT TO BELIEVE THAT
COURT JUDGE HAS GOT TO BE
LIVED AND FURIOUS TONIGHT.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS THE LETTER THAT
DEVIN NUNES HAS SENT TODAY
TO THE PRESIDING JUDGE OF
THE FISA COURT REQUESTING
NOT ONE BUT FOUR DIFFERENT
MISREPRESENTATIONS OF FACT
THAT WERE MADE ALLEGEDLY BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THE FBI DURING THOSE
HEARINGS.
IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE
GRASSLEY GRAHAM LETTER, IT
WAS CONCEALED BUT IT MAY BE
EVEN WORSE IN THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS LEON PANETTA
CASS WRONG WHEN HE SAID THE
INTEL COMMITTEE DIDN'T EVEN
INTERVIEW THE JUDGES.
I GOT NEWS FOR THEM.
THEY HAD NO AUTHORITY TO DO
THAT.
TODAY TO GET THEIR HANDS ON
THE TRANSCRIPTS OF THE
HEARINGS BEFORE THOUGH FISA
JUDGES.
>> LET ME GO TO TOM FITTON.
THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF BARACK
STRZOK AND PAGE TALKING
POINTS FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAYS
IT WAS KNOT ABOUT THE EMAIL
INVESTIGATION BUT FROM
EARLIER COMMENTS I SAW THAT
YOU MADE, YOU HAVE YOUR
DOUBTS ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, YOU PICK.
IT'S EITHER ABOUT THE EMAIL
INVESTIGATION OR RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
EITHER WAY YOU SEE PRESIDENT
OBAMA BEING INTENSELY
INVOLVED IN WANTING TO KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT EITHER THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION
OR RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
PICK YOUR POISON.
IN TERMS OF PRESIDENTIAL
INVOLVEMENT IN THE SENSITIVE
DEMOCRATICALLY
INVESTIGATION.
NOW, I'VE ALWAYS WONDERED
WHY PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS
SKATED REALLY FREE FROM ANY
SERIOUS INQUIRIES ABOUT HIS
INVOLVEMENT IN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, HIS KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THE DOSSIER ITS
ORIGINS, SEA POLITICIAN TOO
RUNNING THE DNC IN PART.
DID HE KNOW ABOUT THE
PAYMENT OF THE DNC AND
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE
DID HE KNOW ABOUT THE
DOSSIER'S USE?
I WOULD THINK TO JUSTIFY
UNMASKING.
THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT
HAVE TO BE ASKED OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> Sean: ABSOLUTELY.
>> THIS PRESIDENT IS BEING
CRIMINALLY INVESTIGATED
ABOUT HIS COMMUNICATION WITH
THE FBI DIRECTOR ABOUT A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
WHY ISN'T THERE SIMILAR
INQUIRIES INTO WHAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS DOING?
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT JODI
GENERAL HAVE A
GENERAL HAVE A JOE DIGENOVA.
IF THAT'S NOT BAD ENOUGH,
NOW WE HAVE THE INFORMATION
THAT LOOKS LIKE SAID VICIOUS
BLUMENTHAL AND DEPARTMENT OF
STATE ARE COMPLICIT IN
PROVIDING STEELE SOME OF
CLINTON CAMPAIGN TO
DISSEMINATE TO THE LAZY
OVERPAID SO-CALLED
JOURNALISTS MEDIA IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> HERE'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
THIS SHOWS THAT THE FBI WAS
BOOT STRAPPING ALL OF THE
A CIRCULAR FIRING SQUAD SO
THAT ALL THE INFORMATION WAS
BASED ON THE SAME
INFORMATION THEREFORE
NOTHING BEING PRESENTED TO
THE FISA COURT WAS ACTUALLY
VERIFIABLE.
LET ME SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
LEON PANETTA.
I SAW HIS COMMENTS THIS
WEEKEND WHERE HE CONDEMNED
CHAIRMAN NUNES FOR
POLITICIZING INTELLIGENCE.
WHAT A DISGRACEFUL COMMENT
BY A FORMER CIA DIRECTOR.
LEON PANETTA SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF HIMSELF.
HE IS OBVIOUSLY NOT READING
HAS NOT READ THE APRIL 26TH,
THE FBI OF PURPOSEFULLY AND
ILLEGALLY AND UP
CONSTITUTIONALLY LEAKING
FISA 702 INFORMATION TO
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS, WHICH
IS A FELONY.
YOU'VE NEVER HEARD
MR. PANETTA SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT ANY OF THE CONDUCT OF
JOHN BRENNAN, THE SINGLE
MOST POLITICAL CIA DIRECTOR
IN HISTORY.
AND BRENNAN'S COMMENTS THIS
WEEKEND ABOUT ALL OF THE
STUFF THAT NUNES IS DOING
RANK AMONG THE MOST
DISGUSTING POLITICAL
>> Sean: WOW.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT BRENNAN
AND CLAPPER.
I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT THE
SURVEILLANCE, UNMASKING,